on behalf of everyone involved in
counterterrorism and wider policing i'd
like to offer my deepest condolences to
the family
friends and colleagues of sadavid who
died so tragically last
friday sir david's dedication to his
family his constituents
and his community
and his positive impact on the lives of
so many have been abundantly clear since
his death
specialist officers continue to support
to david's family
and all of our sympathies are with them
i would also like to recognize the
courage and professionalism of officers
from essex police and paramedics for
their response
to the incident
as you know
last friday sir david tragically died
from serious injuries after being
stabbed at a constituency surgery in lee
on sea a man was arrested at the scene
since then
the mets counter-terrorism command has
led the investigation
a large team of detectives have been
working around the clock to find out as
much as we can about what happened
and why
that work has included searches of a
number of london addresses
our advanced forensics teams have
analyzed digital devices
and carried out a painstaking review
of cctv footage
i also want to thank witnesses
and members of the public who have
supported the investigation
information
as a result of all of that work
today
we have reached a significant milestone
following the submission of a file of
evidence to the crown prosecution
service
charges have been authorized
ali harvey alley aged 25
and from north london
has been charged with murder
and the preparation of terrorist acts
contrary to section 5 of the terrorism
act
2006
ali remains in custody
and will appear at westminster
magistrates court this afternoon
we will continue to build our case
if there are members of the public who
have further information that might help
the investigation i would urge them to
come forward
every piece of information in
investigations like this is important
and you will not be wasting our time
please contact us through the
anti-terrorist hotline
it remains the case that no other
arrests have been made and at this time
we are not seeking anybody else in
relation to this incident
there has been considerable speculation
in the media about the background
history and motivation of the man now
charged
i understand the interest in these
questions and of course they form part
of our investigation
however
now charges have been bought we will not
be providing further information on any
aspects of this case
and i would strongly urge anyone
interested in the case to exercise
restraint when commenting on it publicly
we all have an interest in ensuring
future court proceedings are not
prejudiced in any way
i would also like to reiterate the
request made by sir david's family
that their privacy be respected
i fully understand the significant
impact that the attack on sir david has
had on his colleagues in the houses of
parliament
we've been working closely with
parliament's own security team and with
the home office to review existing
arrangements for mp security and that
work will continue
police forces across the country have
been working with individual mps to
review their specific arrangements
alongside this case
it's important for me to stress
counterterrorism officers across the uk
and the security service and other
partners are working night and day to
bear down on the threat from terrorism
our communities play a vital role in
those efforts
every day information given to the
public given to the police by the public
helps our investigations
if you see or hear something suspicious
trust your instincts
contact the police phone us or contact
us in confidence
online
in respect of this investigation
although charges have been laid our work
continues
and whilst it does
sir david's family remain in our
thoughts